-Thank you for being here
in person.
The last time you were very nice
to us and you zoomed.
-I zoomed from my apartment,
and I was wearing sweatpants.
-Oh, yeah, but I didn't know.
-Below.
-I was wearing a Chanel jacket,
but, you know,
underneath it
was a sad situation.
-Yeah.
Are you still living in London?
Or are you back living
in New York?
-I was living in London,
then I moved home
back with my parents up until
about a week ago.
-No.
-And now I live here --
-Uh-huh.
-For a month, and then I go
to wherever --
-To other movies and things.
-Yes. Yes, yes.
-So you really don't really
have a home.
-I don't have a home.
-No.
You're just traveling
and just being everywhere.
And right now,
I don't have a job either.
So I'm --
-[Laughing] Oh, my gosh.
-I'm looking for something.
-Wow. You were telling me
backstage
you have a new obsession.
What is this?
-Formula 1.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know if it's, like,
a big thing here yet.
But In Europe, it's --
-Massive.
-It's massive.
-No, in America, it is big.
But I don't know in New York
if it's that big.
-Well --
-Is it?
-Yeah, New York, I don't know.
-I don't know if it --
-Yeah, New Yorkers,
we take our time.
We go, "Well, we're not sure."
-Well, I'm going to make you all
get into it.
-Okay. Tell us.
School us.
So, there's this show on Netflix
called "Drive to Survive."
During the pandemic I didn't
really do anything, obviously,
like everyone else.
-Yeah.
-But I watched this show,
and now --
-"Drive to Survive"?
-"Drive to Survive," on Netflix.
It follows all the drivers,
the Formula 1 drivers.
I never cared about sports
before, by the way.
And now, I'm completely hooked.
They're all gorgeous.
-Yeah.
-It's like --
it's like a boy band
kind of thing.
You follow their lives.
Also, one of the team
principals, the boss
of Red Bull, is married
to Geri Horner,
who's a Spice Girl.
-Oh, yeah, Geri.
-So, that's --
There's something for everyone.
-Yeah.
-And it's really fun.
And so -- actually, Brad Pitt
is making a Formula 1 movie.
[ Cheers ]
-Yeah.
-And I have the same manager
as Brad Pitt.
Flex.
-Okay, now we're --
now we're getting somewhere.
-So, I was at dinner with my
manager, and I was obviously
talking about it.
And she was like, "Oh, he's
making a movie about it."
And I was like, "Get Brad Pitt
on the phone right now."
[ Laughter ]
And she called him.
-She did?
-And I said, "I will do anything
in this movie.
I will have one line,
I will be in the pit crew,
I will do whatever you want."
-Yeah.
-But I've got to be
in this film.
-And -- And I am obsessed with
Formula 1, yeah.
-Obsessed.
And he said, "I'm such a fan.
I watched 'Behind Her Eyes'
twice.
You're in it, kid."
-What?!
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's how you -- that's how
you make stuff happen.
-Yeah.
-Wow!
Do we know where
and how you're in it?
-I have no clue.
-No.
But I feel like we had a verbal
agreement over the phone,
and if you say it on national
television, it's legally binded.
-It's legal.
Yes, that is correct.
We have lawyers here that will
say that it is legal.
Yeah.
-So, that's fine.
So, if I'm not in that movie,
give him hell the next time --
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
All right, I'm going to be into
both of those things.
I want to talk about
"Bad Sisters,"
which I'm totally into,
by the way.
-Yay.
-It's great, it's fantastic,
it's a good plot.
I love the whole idea of it.
You shot it in Ireland.
-Mm-hm.
-You scared me when you jumped
off that cliff, by the way.
-I know. I scared everyone
when I did that.
-Yeah.
You don't have to do that stuff.
-I know. That's what
the stunt people told me,
but I was preparing to jump into
the water and my friend who does
it everyday -- it's kind of an
Irish thing, that we jump into
Irish Sea and --
It's to get over your hangover,
basically.
-Oh, there you go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now I know
what you're talking about.
Yeah, yeah.
And when we got to actually
shoot the scene,
they just asked me
to jump off the steps.
And I was like, "Oh, no, no, no,
no, no, I've been scaring the...
out of myself every weekend
to do this."
So, I asked them if I could jump
off the cliff.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, in Dublin.
And here you go.
Look at this.
Rebel without a cause,
right there.
Just jumping off.
Scaring everyone.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But that's you putting your all
into --
-I know, I was like
"We're making a TV show."
-That's the type of stuff
that they need in
that Formula 1 movie
with Brad Pitt.
You'll be jumping off stuff.
Yeah, exactly.
-I don't know if they jump in
Formula 1,
but I'll make it happen.
-This driver does.
You jump into your car.
-[ Laughs ]
-But, can we explain what
"Bad Sisters," the plot of this?
And congrats on the great
reviews, by the way.
Well-deserved.
-I think one of the reviews
said,
"It's the Avengers
assembles of Irish talent."
-Yeah! That's exact--
not too shabby, right there.
-I was like, "Oh, I like that."
-Yeah, I love it.
I like that it starts off --
Well, you explain it
and then I'll tell you
what I like about it.
-Okay. So it's about
five Irish sisters
who hate one of their sisters'
husbands.
-And he's the worst.
-Because he is the worst.
-He is the worst.
-He is a terrible,
despicable human being.
-Yes.
-And so, they decide
to kill him.
[ Laughter ]
And they have absolutely
no business being murderers.
They're terrible at it.
[ Laughter ]
And there is all these awful
failed attempts.
And you know he's dead
from the first episode.
-That's what I was going to say.
I like that.
'Cause you don't have to go,
"Oh, are they going --"
He's dead.
-He's dead.
-Someone killed him.
-It opens with his funeral.
And then -- but you just
don't know who did it.
-It's well done.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Eve Hewson
in "Bad Sisters."
Take a look at this.
-I want in.
I want to help.
-No.
No way.
-You're pushing me out, Eva.
You're not being my mom,
or my sister, or my friend.
-Yeah, well fine if I'm not
being any of those things,
but I'm not going to stop
protecting you --
-You're not protecting me!
-Because that is my job.
-You're isolating me.
-I don't even know why
I'm having to --
What we're doing is really,
really bad.
-No, it's not.
It's survival.
Someone's not coming out
the other side of this.
And it's not going to be me.
And it sure as [bleep] is not
going to be one of my sisters.
-Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
"Bad Sisters" assemble!
-[ Laughs ]
Eve Hewson, everybody.
"Bad Sisters" premieres
this Friday on Apple TV plus.
Fallon Book Club author
Gabrielle Zevin
joins us after the break.
Stick around, everybody.